si vous avez lu votre quotidien La
Presse ce matin et surtout le papier
d'Isabelle laché vous avez peut-être eu
un petit peu ressentir un petit peu
beaucoup d'indignation
sur l'histoire de cette jeune mère qui
soulève vraiment des questions sur les
droits des enfants et ceux des violeurs
condamnés pour leur crime l'enfant de
cette femme et
issu donc de viol l'agresseur est en
prison il est exigeait un test de
paternité il va inscrire son nom sur le
certificat de naissance de l'enfant sur
les registres de l'état civil et on est
en présence d'un bébé ici alors il est
bien le père les tests ont été faits il
rétrend il réclame donc ses droits mais
évidemment qu'en est-il de ses droits et
surtout des droits de l'enfant et puis
aussi ce qu'on fait vivre à la mer deux
invités de belachi journalistes à la
presse et à Leroy bonsoir à vous deux je
commence avec Isabelle lacher maître Roy
Isabelle qu'est-ce qui vous a amené à
traiter de cette histoire puisqu'on doit
retenir de l'essentiel de cette histoire
selon vous parce qu'il m'a amené comme
n'importe quel histoire on a attiré
c'est un lecteur qui attirer mon
attention sur cette histoire là donc qui
m'a envoyé le jugement qui est public et
quand j'ai lu le jugement comme tout le
monde je pense que j'ai eu un choc j'ai
trouvé ça absolument aberrant absolument
révoltant donc j'ai voulu en savoir plus
j'ai retrouvé la victime donc la jeune
mère qui avait seulement 18 ans quand
elle était violée par son colocataire en
fait par son colocataire
non non c'est une personne qui connaisse
qu'elle connaissait depuis longtemps
depuis l'enfance mais seulement 18 ans
et ils sont partis étant ensemble en
colocation depuis seulement quelques
jours donc est-ce qu'il se passe c'est
que c'était la nuit le soir elle se
lavait les cheveux dans le lavabo et le
pas entendu son colocataire entrer dans
la salle de bain quand elle s'est
retournée il était devant lui
complètement à nu
il a traîné en fait j'ai essayé de
essayer de la noyer presque vraiment mis
sa tête sous l'eau pendant qu'elle est
en train de se laver les cheveux ensuite
l'inquiétude il y a plusieurs
inquiétudes chez cette femme-là de
devoir parce que c'est une personne
assez dangereuse il y a quand même
attaqué quatre personnes dans elle il le
violet brutalement
il y a des risques de récidive important
et votre surveillance pendant plusieurs
années quand tu vas sortir de prison
c'est un homme dangereux donc
effectivement le très peur de lui il est
terrorisée terrorisée aussi du fait que
elle puisse devoir expliquer un jour à
son enfant que son père est un violeur
que chaque fois qu'elle sort son
certific connaissance le nom du père
soit là elle veut pas ça du tout elle
veut pas avoir rien à voir avec cette
cette personne là elle a été obligée
elle est obligée de se soumettre au test
de l'ADN pour confirmer ça n'avait pas
le choix la juge la course supérieure a
rendu cette décision c'est une
ordonnance ou de la cour donc elle a pas
eu le choix la course est basée sur le
droit de l'enfant à reconnaître à
connaître ses origines donc c'est
là-dessus beaucoup que le droit se base
ici au Québec je laisserai peut-être
mais c'est ce qui s'est passé
effectivement beaucoup de aujourd'hui
énormément parce que cette fameuse seule
devant la justice aussi ça lui impose
des marges considérables
devant la justice puis être obligé de
retourner parce que là comme
effectivement ça a été le test de d'ADN
prouvé que c'était bien bel et bien le
père ils vont retourner en cause c'est
pas terminé pour elle c'est le cauchemar
on va continuer lui ne lâchera pas pris
vous êtes quand même un grand
spécialiste de droit civil vous avez
conseillé le milieu de la justice sur la
réforme du droit de la famille c'était
très important pour vous depuis des
années vous avez été très patient
d'ailleurs
écoutez quand on dit que la juge
Isabelle Germain rendu un bon jugement
dans le droit tel que c'est vrai ça en
fait c'est que il y a plusieurs concepts
encore dans cette histoire-là qui semble
être amalgamé il y a la filiation c'est
à dire le statut légal de père il y a
l'autorité parentale et il y a la
connaissance des origines
sur le plan de la filiation
effectivement
la juge applique le droit tel qu'il
existe c'est-à-dire sans tenir compte
des circonstances de la naissance et ça
c'est un principe qu'on a dans le Code
civil depuis
1980 il faut bien comprendre que si on a
adopté ce principe là c'est au nom des
droits de l'enfant parce qu'on ne
voulait pas que l'enfant soit pénalisé
en raison des circonstances de sa
naissance comme on le faisait avant par
exemple avec l'enfant et ses studieux
celui qu'on qualifiait d'incestieux on
le privait de droit alimentaire en
raison des circonstances de sa naissance
alors en 80 on a dit non
on doit établir la filiation sans égard
à ce qui s'est passé
alors la juge applique correctement le
droit quant à la filiation cela dit
ça ne veut pas dire que ce monsieur là
même si son statut de père est reconnu
légalement qu'il aura l'autorité
parentale et Laura un recours en
déchéance d'autorité parentale et un jeu
2022 donc il y a quelques semaines il y
a une modification importante qui est
apportée dans le Code civil l'intérêt de
l'enfant maintenant doit être envisagé à
la lumière de la violence familiale qui
inclut la violence conjugale
en plus c'est un crime exact mais c'est
de la violence au sens très large
violence familial à tout le moins et là
on peut pas dire que bon peut-être pas
un bon conjoint ou un bon coup là mais
ça va être un bon père il y a des
raisonnements de juges qui ont été un
peu à cet effet-là dans le passé et
l'ont contrecar complètement alors
déchéance d'autorité parentales de sorte
à ce que il ne puisse plus
exercer quelques pouvoirs
donc aucun pouvoir décisionnel pas
d'accès pas de garde évidemment c'est un
recours autre le nom apprendre un avocat
à être seul devant la justice encore
exactement le nom c'est autre chose le
juge au moment où il va reconnaître le
statutaire n'a pas l'obligation mais
absolument pas d'attribuer à l'enfant le
nom du père
la connaissance des origines c'est un
tout autre enjeu et ça c'est un peu
curieux que la juge trouve comme
fondement la filiation la connaissance
des origines parce que la filiation
équivaut pas toujours aux origines loin
de là en matière d'adoption par exemple
de procréation assistée on voit qu'une
dissociation et c'est un droit de
l'enfant de connaître ses origines
indépendamment de la filiation c'est à
dire que cet enfant-là au moment où il
aura atteint un certain âge pourrait
vouloir connaître ses origines aussi
cruelles l'absurde soit-elle et ça on
peut pas l'en empêcher mais là c'est pas
un enfant qui exerce un droit dans le
jugement là donc on met l'enfant devant
cette idée que ses origines doivent lui
être divulgués dévoiler ses origines
génétiques c'est pas ça le droit à la
connaissance des origines c'est un droit
qui appartient à l'enfant et qui se
relève d'exercer l'intérêt de l'enfant
arrive où à quel moment parce que là
pour la déchéance de l'autorité
parentale on va invoquer l'intérêt de
l'enfant également et c'est un critère
et c'est un critère
dont on devrait peut-être tenir compte
dans une situation comme celle-ci au
niveau de la filiation parce que je vous
disais que la juge avait appliqué le
droit correctement ça veut pas dire que
ce droit là est logique là
écoutez la filiation on en connaît
maintenant les implications identitaires
alors on aurait beau des choix
complètement monsieur de sorte à ce
qu'il n'y ait plus de pouvoir
décisionnel il reste que l'identité de
l'enfant se construit à partir d'une
paternité comme celle-là certainement
pas dans l'intérêt de l'enfant alors à
mon sens serait tout à fait envisageable
pertinent adéquat de bloquer
l'établissement de la filiation
lorsque l'enfant est issu d'un viol ou
lorsque sa conception est liée un climat
de violence comme celle-là je disais
aussi dans votre papier vous avez reçu
ce matin qui a plusieurs États
américains qui ont légéré qui interdit
qui prive le violeur de cette filiation
là aujourd'hui bien comprendre que le
ministre de la Justice réagit miroir
risquer la député libéral ça serait
beaucoup le tennis on devrait légiférer
rapidement pour même ces décors il y en
a quand même quelques centaines je crois
j'ai pas réussi au Québec aux États-Unis
par année le tiers à peu près
320 c'est ça de le conserver par la
suite mais il faut en venir à voir
l'affiliation pour ce qu'elle est
souvent les juristes vont vous dire ah
ben écoutez il faut agir sur l'autorité
parentale donc si le monsieur peut être
déchu de son autorité parentale on
atteint l'objectif il sera pas dans le
décor il y aura pas d'accès il y aura
pas de garde il y aura pas de pouvoir
décisionnel
alors il y a pas dit qu'un jour cet
enfant-là voudra pas connaître ses
origines et ça c'est un droit qui lui
appartient si on lui donne le soutien
psychosocial qui s'impose parce que bon
il y a un secret qui va être difficile à
gérer mais c'est sa prérogative alors je
vois pas en quoi ces problématiques et
je vois pas non plus en quoi ça vient
interférer avec la filiation c'est des
enjeux complètement différents
alors forcément en novembre ou dans les
mois qui suivent cette question là va
être à l'ordre du jour j'imagine merci
Isabelle haché de nous avoir alerté
là-dessus merci de vous lire merci à moi
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]